ACTUALLY, THE CONSERVATIVE --
>> Mark: WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT
THERE, KATIE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
11 REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HAS SENT A
LETTER TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, CALLING FOR THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS OF A --
WAIT FOR IT TO -- JAMES COMEY,
HILLARY CLINTON, ANDREW
McCABE, AND LORETTA LYNCH.
CHIEF NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
ED HENRY HAS MORE ON THAT.
ADD.
>> MARKET, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
STILL DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
MOVING QUICKLY ENOUGH ON ALLEGED
ABUSES BY THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE LIKING OF TOP
ADVISORS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO CONGRESSMAN AND TEN OTHER
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT TAKEN
THE INITIATIVE TO TAKE THIS TO
THE FBI.
AND IT TO -- HE WAS TASKED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S TO
EVALUATE WHAT NEEDS TO BE
CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR ACTIONS
LIKE ABUSE OF A FISA OBAMA
OFFICIALS.
AT THE TOP OF THEIR LIST FOR
POTENTIAL CHARGES AS YOU
MENTIONED, HILLARY CLINTON, FOR
USING FUSION GPS TO DISCUSS
PAYMENTS FROM HER PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IT NOT TO DISCLOSE WITH TOP
OFFICIALS, SPYING ON THE FORMER
TRUMP ADVISOR.
THERE IS NO MERIT TO THIS CLAIM
AND REPUBLICANS MUST BE ACTING
UP HERE BECAUSE THEY ARE SCARED
ABOUT THE UPCOMING MIDTERMS.
THAT IS THEIR VIEW.
ALSO PEOPLE LIKE PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE, THE ANTITRUST
TEXT MESSAGES, SEEMING TO REVEAL
A BIAS.
FORMER FBI ACHIEVED JAMES COMEY
ALSO A TARGET FOR SIGNING THREE
PHIS APPLICATIONS WITHOUT
DISCLOSING THE FUNDING FROM THE
CLINTON CAMP FOR THE DOSSIER AS
WELL AS THE FACT THAT HE DRAFTED
AND EXONERATION STATEMENTS
MONTHS BEFORE CLINTON'S FBI
INTERVIEW.
THAT APPEARS TO CONTRADICT
TESTIMONY TO CONGRESS.
HE ONLY MADE THE DECISION TO NOT
CHARGE HER AFTER SHE WAS
QUESTIONED BY THE FBI.
HIS FORMER NUMBER TWO, ALSO FOR
LEAKS TO THE MEDIA.
CLASSIFIED INFO GOT OUT FROM THE
RELEASE OF THOSE MEMOS THAT
COMEY PUT TOGETHER.
HE IS CONFIDENT THAT HE WILL BE
EXONERATED.
HERE IS WHERE IT GETS
INTERESTING.
AFTER COMEY TOLD THE VIEW THAT
HE THINKS McCABE IS A GOOD
PERSON BUT HE FOUND THAT HE
LIED, McCABE FIRED BACK.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
AND THAT COMEY IS SIMPLY NOT
BEING HONEST.
SO YOU'VE GOT THE FORMER MEN NOW
TERMING STOMACH TURNING ON EACH
OTHER.
>> THANKS FOR THAT, ADD.
I WILL BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE IT.